in the past week more than a quarter of
those killed in gaza
have been children hamza mahmoud yasin
ali was struck by shrapnel from an
israeli missile in gaza's
shijaya neighborhood on tuesday he was
just 12 years old and died the next day
and two boys from the same family hamada
and amar were killed by strikes from an
israeli helicopter
on the village of al-fukaria the cousins
were 10
and 13. well jason lee is
country director say the children
palestine he joins us via skype
from occupied east jerusalem so just a
couple of examples there of
some of the children who've lost their
lives and that the death toll for
children keeps on rising doesn't it
well it's absolutely horrific i mean out
of the 198 people that have been killed
in gaza
58 of them have been children and not
only the deaths when you look at the
numbers of people being injured
we have a staggering number that since
the start of this conflict on the 14th
of may
we have an average three children being
injured every single
hour and these are lifelong injuries
many of these children were barely
scared
and the long-term physical disability
but also
the incredible tolerance of mental
health for the rest of their lives
and you mentioned those the numbers
injured what how are the hospitals
coping
with with these kind of injuries at the
moment
i mean you've got a hospital system that
has struggled to function with the
blockade
you have a situation now where the
electricity supply
is running out because of the fuel
supplies are running low
you have a situation now where you've
got 38
000 people that are homeless and seeking
shelter in
in the schools and don't forget before
the escalation and the conflict of the
fighting
there was an ongoing covert 19 pandemic
so if you can imagine the situation of
people being overcrowded
the hospitals not having access to
electricity or to water
or sanitation with an ongoing covet 19
pandemic
with lots of injured children coming in
every single day
it's no wonder we have the staggering
devastation
and injuries and deaths that we're
seeing tell me about the families who've
lost their homes because clearly
many people have died but also people
have been made homeless haven't they
what kind of provision
is there for them i mean
these are many people have had to flee
their homes at the last minute with
barely just the clothes in the back and
the ability maybe to pack a few
very very critical documents that they
need my own teams have been affected i
have
several team members that have left
their homes and are now
sheltering in various shelters with
other family members
these people have nothing they have no
idea where the next meal is coming from
where they're going to sleep how they're
going to get medicine for the children
if they're sick
or how do they protect themselves and
the families from covert 19.
tell me about the you you alluded to the
impact on mental health for children
what sort of uh experience do you have i
mean this clearly has happened in the
past and what are the kind of things
that can help
uh to make it less awful for them
i mean i can relay a story that that was
told to me by my teams as own or
speaking to them
i mean they're obviously very scared and
and fearful for their children and
they see the changes in behavior with
their children the children are now
fearful they no longer want to play
they're always looking at the window
wondering what's going to happen
and most parents try and put a brave
face and lie to their children saying
everything's okay
telling the children that the airstrikes
are fireworks
but what what would any parent say to
their child
if the child asks them will we still
have a home tomorrow
will i still be here tomorrow
what what do you say i mean what can you
say this is the impact that we're having
on children
it is unfathomable that children
witness and experience the horror
devastation and destruction of war and
to think that this is normal for them
this is what we're doing to children
uh you speak very powerfully the the
situation for children and parents uh
in in gaza how difficult is it for your
teams to
carry out any kind of help i mean that
the you mentioned that some of them are
having to run from that for their for
their own lives
are you able to to provide help at the
moment
at the moment it is impossible because
of the ongoing fighting
in gaza this is why it is imperative
first and foremost that there is an
immediate cease-fire
that means that israel has to stop the
airstrikes and the incursions
into gaza hamas has to stop the rockets
and all sides have to take immediate
immediate steps
to protect civilians to safeguard
the safety and lives of civilians and to
ensure that there is safe
unfitted and unrestricted access for
humanitarians to deliver
life-saving assistance this is what we
need to do immediately
jason lee from save the children
palestine thank you very much indeed for
talking to us on al jazeera
thank you